nous passons
ensuite à l'amendement 791 défendu par
Madame ponon vous avez la parole chers
collègues merci monsieur le
Président l'inflation dans les outrerses
gonfle des prix déjà élevés en effet une
étude de l'Autorité de la concurrence
datant de 2019 relevait que le niveau
général des prix était plus élevé que
dans l'exagone soulignant un écart de
supérieur à 12 % en Martinique et
Guadeloupe et de 7 % dans la Réunion la
grande pauvreté définie comme la
combinaison de faible revenus et de
privation matérielle et sociale sévère
et plus présente dans les collectivités
territoriales d'outremer selon l'INC 24
% des personnes concernées par une
situation de grande pauvreté vivent dans
les drôes alors que ces territoires
rassemblent seulement 3 % de la
population nationale soit une
surreprésentation dans un rapport de 8
par conséquent les hausses de prix dans
les territoires d' ma combiné à un taux
de pauvreté largement supérieur à
l'Hexagone multiplie les les situations
sociales critiques à la Réunion les
enfants sont particulièrement touchés
par la pauvreté puisque 46 % d'entre eux
vivent dans un ménage pauvre ainsi on
peut lire concrètement des milliers
d'enfants on faim ont soif ne peuvent se
laver ne peuvent aller à l'école et
cette situation demeure largement
méconnue des citoyens français selon le
rapport de la Cour des comptes présenté
à la commission des finances du Sénat je
cite malgré les investissements
importants isé par l'État dans les
territoires ultramarins d'évidentes
inégalités persiste en matière de
transport d'infrastructure
d'assainissement de télécommunication
d'accès au logement social cet
amendement se propose donc de définir un
taux particulier de TVA à
1,05 % Guadeloupe Martinique et la
Réunion tau qui existe d'ailleurs déjà
pour ces territoires sur certains
articles et là notamment il s'agirait
des produits de toilettes et d'hygiène
personnelle y compris protection
hygiénique féminine les produits
d'entretien domestique les produits et
les fournitures scolaires je vous
remercie chers collègues quel est l'avis
de la commission défvorable la viis du
gouvernement défavorable je mets au voix
oui monsieur Lurel vous avez la parole
pardon
excusez-moi non non mais madame monsieur
le Président j'entends mon rappor qu'il
est défavorable il n'a pas de cœur ce ce
rapporteur pourtant un excellent homme
par ailleurs quant au au au ministres et
son gouvernement depuis 2017 on voit
l'rition euh s'abattre sur les autres
mèes et notre excellent collègue cite un
certain nombre de rapports qui vont tous
dans le même sens la pauvreté la
précarité la vie chè la concentration
les monopoles comment peut-on pratiquer
une telle politique et en guise de
réponse vous nous dites oh la mission
autremaire est passée de 200liard 3
maintenant 200 milliard 9 mais en même
temps dans le même temps c'est tout à
fait ma maronier ça euh euh vous
réduisez toutes les libertés laissées
aux collectivités aux ménages aux
associations et aux citoyens vous
diminuez ou vous supprimez toutes les
euh euh des fiscalisations qui existent
et ensuite quand vous votez un budget en
exécution il n'est pas exécuté on a des
restes à payer considérabl le logement
n'avance pas il y a des fils d'attente
pour le logement social l'intermédiaire
il y a des côas et c'est le préfet qui
décide bref c'est une catastrophe al
oryz un peu de cœur
ouvrez-le merci monsieur Lurel je mets
au voix cet amendement qui reçu deux
avis négatifs qui est
pour qui est
contre
je vous propose de faire un assis
debout donc que ceux qui sont pour cet
amendement se lèv s'il vous
plaît 4 5 6
20 merci ceux qui sont contre se
lève l'amendement est
adopté